hey guys how's it going so I just got
these two boxes in the mail and I was so
excited to open them up that I didn't
even feel like setting up my a proper
unboxing station so we're just gonna get
right into this because I think I know
what's inside of here Mophie had a
really cool announcement the other day
about some of the fun stuff that they
have coming out and I'm a part of this
really cool program with them where they
send us stuff to check out us do what we
do
whoa whoa whoa here it is clearly don't
need a knife for this we're gonna use it
prepare your bodies my body's ready it
is what I thought it was see how this
thing called hold force it basically
added a magnetic connection to your
phone case which will allow you to have
your Mophie chargers stick to the back
of this might sound kind of crazy but
that's already what people do and how
they carry their movies like right now
this is sitting on the floor this is how
I always carry my movies with them
attached like this clearly this idea
isn't something that's new I think it's
like the Motorola or something they have
like those snap-on so basically you
select a case and then you select an
attachment accessories there's all kinds
of things that you can attach to it they
have like these little sexually there
may be something in this other box so I
don't know what's in here so we're gonna
need to open this up and see if there's
accessories in here I gotta be careful
cuz I don't want to hurt myself
oh yeah this I wonder what's in here oh
my gosh if it's all the accessories my
heart oh no well here's the problem oh I
don't have an iPhone 7 this is for the
iPhone 7 but it shows you oh this is
cool like a little wallet so they have
these things also for the 7 plus well
shoot I'm going to need to give this to
somebody about an iPhone 7 because I
can't use this but this is what it does
here's your iPhone case it's got these
magnetic little back to it and 6 so this
is like a little wallet version here's a
movie charge pack you stick to the case
and what's great about these is they've
got this little cord right here and you
can just stick it right into your phone
this is really cool this is the little
folio case wallet in there so you can
put like a little credit cards in here
and it just attaches very nicely to your
iPhone and it folds up like a little
it's like the the original iPad cover
cases I'm into it so basically what this
means is one of you guys with an iPhone
7 you're gonna have to let me know
basically what I did for the giveaway
previously on V Gears of War Xbox I had
you guys leave me a comment tell me that
you have an iPhone 7 but I'm gonna need
you to prove it you have an iPhone 7 so
that I can make sure that this is going
to a good home
this is an iPhone 7 plus this is iPhone
7 so leave a comment below if you have
an iPhone 7 or if you have a friend that
has an iPhone 7 maybe you don't perhaps
you might be able to win this for them
so leave me a comment telling me if you
have one or a friend has one and then
take a screenshot of your comment on
youtube and tweet it to me tweak the
screenshot but also bonus points in
between a picture of yourself with an
iPhone 7 so that I know you're not a
liar so with this you're gonna get this
cute little folio case I'm so jealous
it's so nice this little wallet I will
give you one of the chargers and because
I'm so sweet I'm going to give you a
people tiny little USB cable which I
absolutely love I have been
electing these because I have a little
power station charger so these are
sometimes hard to come by so I will give
it to you because you're gonna need it
to charge your items I'm gonna save this
little box for you guys because it'll I
can ship it in this cuz I know I've got
all this paper
amazing they're just gonna ship it in
the box that it came in you guys are
gonna get a lot of presents we're gonna
get all these I am gonna keep this one
though because I'm already giving you
one anyway let me know what you guys
think of these I think it's a great idea
I'm definitely gonna have to get one for
my seven plus now because I always am
carrying my phone like this and to be
able to have my charger basically be
attached to it and I can carry it and
not worry that you have one of the
things are gonna fall off I'm into it I
think it's great so good luck to all of
those who enter and I hope that you guys
will enjoy your new little presents and
whoever wins make sure you guys tweet me
a picture so that I know that you got
them safely and just clarify I will be
picking a winner off of Twitter and
that's how I will contact you because
sometimes contacting people on YouTube
there's a lot of spam and people get
confused so I don't want there to be any
confusion I will tweet you on Twitter to
let you know that you won so best of
luck I love you guys and I'm very
jealous because these are so cool see
you later I really sure where it is I
don't think I'm ever going to be able to
get this entire place put together here
it is there's a lot of Maddie's toys
everywhere so I think it will look
better once we have Maddie's toys all
taken care of so now we got to figure
out the chair situation if you like I
need something over there in that corner
now these rugs already